we're going to do boof ons needle trick
so this is named after George Louie
Leclerc and this is a method that he
proposed for working out pi
so racing he proposed that you would
Chuck a bunch of needles on just
randomly on a floor yeah you can work
out PI from that yeah yeah due to the
random nature so we haven't got needles
and we're not gonna do on a floor we're
gonna do it on of Freddie's lovely brown
pieces of paper and we're gonna use
matches instead because because we're
cheap so what we want is we want the we
want to draw some lines on this so
there's one line and what we want is we
want the gaps between lines to be two
matches long this is all very
approximate what we're going to do is
we're going to chalk a bunch of matches
on this same on this port so I'll just
shut the first two completely randomly
I've got weed a lot of matches for this
if I counted these right we should have
163 let's just spread them out so
hopefully there should be 163 matches
randomly distributed around this board
now this is what I gotta do now is I'm
gonna count how many matches cross a
line okay so I reckon that one does so
you can't and brady that's one two three
five six eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifty one and I think that's it 52 52
matches that cross the lines there's 163
in total now let's see em let's do the
following calculation so 163 divided by
52 is equal to three point one three
that's not bad that's not bad then quite
a few yeah yeah so pi is 3.14 one so
this is this is this is not bad and okay
so why isn't it perfect because this is
not a very large sample and you know
viewers could could have a little go
themselves just literally play the same
game if you've got more matches that's
better you'll get better accuracy there
was a a mathematician called Lazzarini
he used over 3,000 and
needles and he actually managed to get
and pie accurate sort of I think it's
about six decimal places what we're
seeing here is something akin to a Monte
Carlo simulation that's what it's called
you basically take a random sample the
reason you get pie out of this is it's
all to do the angle that the match takes
is being sort of you know playing some
role here again of course if you're
working in radians if you go through a
full what we've got 360 degrees one in
radians that's two pi okay so that's
where PI is coming into this game and
that's why you can get PI out of this
sort of setup because of the angle
so we're going to try and explain the
mass of it now let me say imagine it
that the length of the match is L okay
and that means that the distance here is
two well here's what we there's a few
things that play a role here
there's the position of the center of
the match which I'll call there we'll
say that's a distance X from here and
then the other thing that we're
interested in is the angle that the
match is making so let's just draw it I
guess like so we're interested in that
angle theta human everything's
completely random what's the probability
density know how do we measure the
probability of where the center of the
matches well the probability density of
the at the center of the match this is
the position x is just given by
essentially one over else the other
thing that we're interested in is the
angle that it makes so this is sort of a
measure of the probability of the angle
it's making and basically the angular
angles that were interested in is
somewhere between zero and PI over 2
which is of course 90 degrees it is
where the PI's coming in now if we want
to work out essentially that you know
the the probability of matches that for
the match to cross that cross the line
what we do is we take these two let's do
an integration okay now there's an
important point here what's the
condition so the match to cross the line
well the condition for the match to
cross the line is that X should be less
than L over 2 sine theta so that means
when we do the X integration we go
between 0 and L over 2 sine theta okay
and of course when we do the theta
integration we're going between 0 and PI
by 2 okay so we do it fetor equals 0 is
PI by 2 2 over and our PI 2 over L PI
when we do the X integration we get an L
over 2 sine theta and then we integrate
sine theta between 0 and PI by 2 that
gives me 1 and I've got the 1 over pi
there so the answer is 1 over pi this
tells me the probability that you're
going to cross the across the line right
so if I've got I've got n matches and I
want to work out how many cross
we call them so this is the end total
okay and I want to work out how many
cross then I just multiplied and totaled
life one over PI we had one sister n
total was 163 and n crossing was was
there was 52 I think we got it didn't we
okay and there so what you see from that
is this we've got 1 6 3 over PI that's
putting approximate side and they're
approximately 52 or if you like what we
actually saw was that PI just rearrange
this equation is approximately 163 yeah
I'm happy with that
yeah yeah that's good so that's how it
works that's the theory behind it
you